[Musique]
la critique est émotionnellement limite
un terrain teinte
j'espérais que vous trouveriez quelque
chose qui puisse expliquer ce qui se
passe lequel est le mieux mais 1 ou le 2
mieux pire pas de différence
pas de différence j'ai bien envie de
savoir ce que tu en penses que la
sobriété de lure a bien réussi père
c'était en plein alcoolisme florissant
à cette époque c'est ce que j'ai dit
j'aurais jamais dû arrêter de boire
aucune originalité aucun courage je ne
peux rien faire pour vous sauver
j'ai trouvé une perle qui a fait ça
hypnotique d'un voisin qui est décédé et
vous vous êtes servi il n'avait ni
famille ni amis je peux vous rendrez
religieux il ya une telle demande qu'ils
sont tous prêts étrangler comme un
artiste du nom de maîtrise
non rien sur nos listes et pourtant on a
tout le monde l'artiste a utilisé son
sens pour créer les roches français
août arrive de regarder cette peinture
n'a jamais rien remarqué de bizarre elle
est vivante
[Musique]
en faisant mes recherches sur 10 je me
suis aperçu que le dégoût de l'argent et
est présent dans toute son oeuvre
10 a passé 20 ans dans un institut
psychiatrique pour criminels
pathologique
tout est en lien avec les offres
un esprit qui émane d'elle
tout est entièrement liée à son art
j'ai l'absolue certitude qui est en
train de se passer quelque chose de
dingue
ici c'est un abattoir
vous êtes au courant que dix avaient
demandé à ce que son oeuvre soit
détruite
oh
desgrange toutes ses toiles
pour que le livre du sûr
je ne peux rien faire pour vous sauver
[Musique]
les gens passaient devant elle comme si
c'était une oeuvre
on a des milliers de vues sur instagram
m'ont pas des records
certains scientifiques ont prédit ce qui
allait arriver mais il était déjà trop
tard
[Musique]
ici ça moi old and si quelqu'un écoute
toujours ses émissions c'était ma
décision de rester sur terre
ici le dr ari walter fréquences
d'émission 90,43 killers le monde que
nous considérions autrefois comme le
nôtre semble s'en prendre à nous le
principe fondamental de la nature et de
survivre c'est nous seuls vous ancrée
dans notre adn mais aussi dans notre âme
de chercher à vivre par tous les moyens
j'ai capté ses transmissions radio où
sont les autres
iec non deux vous avez vu d'autres
villes ouais c'est pareil partout
vous pouvez me dire comment c'était je
veux dire avant je comptais être
professeur on n'était pas prêt pour ça
rejoignez le dernier décollage vers you
on est fait pour mon père il y aune été
que le dernier recours j'ai vu des
dizaines de personnes mourir de faim
parce qu'on lui a fait confiance je ne
commettrai pas la même erreur une
seconde fois et en parquant faut prévoir
notre itinéraire mais on ne doit pas
tarder la route est longue
si jamais on se plante on est fini il
faudra y passer la nuit
c'est pas possible si c'est possible
c'est plus loin que les endroits que
j'ai visités alors c'est parti
le site de lancement étaient déplacés on
est coincés ici
non
crois moi
[Musique]
quelle méthode intérêt que la petite vie
ça m'a mis les réseaux c'est pas la
peine
la réception est hyper mauvaise
je peux la reprendre mais je sais
j'exagère un fusil
[Musique]
débrouillard et c'est une propriété
privée
[Musique]
ils font quoi ils font rien
je pense que si ces barges au rite est
sérieux il nous aurait déjà attaqué
regardez ces bords attendant le massacre
bien tranquille qu'est ce que tu as fait
où est le baby
avec mes frères et soeurs on veut tous
les bébés qu'on peut trouver
ce sont eux l'avenir après tout
il joue avec pau ne s'arrêteront pas
que sans que sans cosse encore encore
encore
mais papa on va tout s'en sortir acheter
un problème les dernières heures d'une
histoire d'amour de l'énigmatique henry
pic évitables trion littéraire madeleine
big je pose la question tout haut que
beaucoup de gens se posent tous pas et
vous certaine que c'est bien votre mari
est écrit ce roman est en train de vous
moquer de mon mari allait vous
l'imaginez le pizzaïolo breton qui
pointent à bouquin de cette envergure
est sérieusement tu as tu vois pas pas
écrire ça entre 210 peter junior qui a
écrit ce livre et je vais trouver
prenez pour qui vous avez le culot de
venir ici mais ça va pas bien vous
pourquoi henry pic
pourquoi toute cette mystification j'ai
besoin de vous pour aller au bout de
cette enquête
vous êtes un peu mon docteur watson
pourquoi ces veaux charlot comme ça
parce que c'est mon enquête
si on pouvait trouver une lettre postée
j'en ai des lettres de lui
ouais c'est pas exactement ce dont je me
souvenais peut-être que ses retombées
sur la liste de courses de proust
oui mais on a retrouvé la liste des
courses de proust et ça a de la gueule
[Musique]
regardez on réplique emporté son secret
dans la tombe
acceptez-le vous allez arrêter de
regarder ma fille c'est quand même pas
nous menacer avec votre binette
non ça c'est une certitude
j'ai presque tout perdu avec ce bouquin
vous êtes en train de bouleverser nos
vies c'est ce livre qui bouleverse nos
vies
c'est pas des fines
vous savez où il habite elle va alors
ils habitent ou diabète la dernière
maison lapointe onu ou infirmières il ya
un problème la viande vers un de ses
gardes et des bas mais que sa palette de
seconde
pourquoi katia a pas il arrêtait cabinet
y ait pu médecin à temps question a
compté beau être au goût moi j'ai pékin
vers les enfants j'ai une nouvelle à
vous annoncer
j'ai abandonné mon cabinet je me suis
consacré uniquement à l'écriture
premièrement pas j'ai rencontré jeudi
femmes qui trouvent que j'ai un style
qui n'est pas sans rappeler tout le secr
ire et le bal pour la première fois
devant une feuille blanche 80 g je
tremble dit m mon empreinte
ok ça rend malade le plus grand
psychanalyste du monde très le cantique
indûment ok tout 30 est censé écrire une
thèse en psychiatrie depuis deux ans
vous avez aucun stop motion en quoi
c'est que j'ai perdu la femme de ma vie
quand même mais ce qui s'est passé les
cuisines culte eux manquent
non j'ai un petit frère de 13 ans
complètement le collègue ait fait ce
qu'on va faire on va prendre un choc
toutes les dix minutes
et au bout du cinquième on va en prendre
un toutes les cinq minutes tu vas vite
et fort un peu comme comme poutine
poutine mais il en reste naturel tu veux
qu'on sorte ensemble non
yvan traverse un épisode compliqué sa
vie avec votre cancer
je n'ai pas de course et vous envoyer
une lettre de refus à mon père faisait
pas censés être amis le roman de votre
appel vous l'avez vu si mauvais que ça
voulait un café masse pato seule quoi
ton frère écrit des poèmes
roddick bio sa classe qu'est ce qui vous
prend tous les deux
[Musique]
pour atténuer ses fils non